okay mic check mic check one two
people of the internet's hello and
welcome to Retro rack and Tour live
as we continue our playthrough of lies
of P
and we are testing out something new
today I'm actually trying to stream
directly from the PlayStation 5.
which I haven't done in a long time
so give me just a second here because
unfortunately when you get it get it
going on the PS5
but then if I want to change anything
like a thumbnail or if I actually want
to see the chat comments from you guys
I have to
enable that
fourth quarter welcome uh no it's not
from the beginning so we started
streaming on Twitch a couple days ago
so I don't think I'm quite to the
halfway point yet but if you recognize
this Arena here that I'm in right now I
just uh beat that boss last night and so
that's where I'm picking up from
how's it going Reaper welcome in dude
that's kind of cool I didn't even know
you could do that how the on the
PlayStation 5
it'll uh pop up with your chat comments
in the bottom right which do you guys
see those two like on my actual screen
and if so are they are they too
distracting or because I can disable
that I've got my laptop sitting here in
front of me I could just uh
oh that's awesome you guys don't see
them Dylan Alicia what's up oh that
makes it even better
that is crazy so that means you could
just stream completely from the TV and
then still see your guys's chat comments
my wife's walking in right now giving me
a very strange look
you can stream straight from the PS5 so
no they can't see you yeah see how
elwin's comment just popped up there
but they don't they don't see that on
their screen
said she said hi Dylan
Alicia says hi to that's pretty cool
isn't it
no I don't have a camera set up she's
worried that you guys are seeing her
foreign
did you need something oh it's in that
box over there
oh and the stream elements bot is
running too that's pretty cool
Ryan what's up Ryan welcome
no I don't think it will pop up with the
alerts L when that is one big downside
now I do have it set up to where well
the stream elements bot wasn't working
but it looks like it's working now so I
think it should still show up in the
chat
but give me one second here I'm just
going to change this thumbnail
to our
lies of P thumbnail
let's go ahead and hit save on that
so yeah there's a little bit more like
setup on the in my my mic's not going to
sound nearly as good you guys probably
already noticed that because it's uh
it's pulling straight from my headset
instead of my actual
sure microphone that I normally use all
right so thumbnails updated okay let me
see if I go to
and I'll go edit all of this out later
so that anybody watching on a replay
darn it I was hoping that I was hoping
on the activity feed and stream elements
that I would still be able to see
but it's not showing up there but yeah
like all the chat comments you guys are
sending they pop up on the bottom right
of my screen and then they just they
vanish after a couple of seconds
but that's awesome that they don't show
up for you guys okay so the alert thing
I would have to figure that out if we
were going to do this
frequently
all right let me mute that
okay yeah I do have my laptop pulled up
in front of me now okay so that's good
all right so let's see let's get caught
up here
we got Dylan with the 14 months Alicia
with the 11 months oh my goodness Alicia
very very close to that 12-month badge
which elwin just unlocked Ellen congrats
on the 12 months there getting that
extra special badge
and if the quality is bad guys you
should be able to hit the little gear on
the YouTube video and actually turn it
all the way up to uh 1080p 60fps so we
had L1 with the 12 months Jenny with the
10 months Jenny welcome back to the
stream good to see you this morning or
almost morning for you it's almost
afternoon for me Ryan De La Cruz welcome
in
yeah I
I didn't plan on doing this at all
but I've been playing this game for as
you guys know for for the next uh trophy
hunt video
and
I thought you know what let's test out
this YouTube streaming thing
and to the to the newcomers welcome in
as well good to see you some new faces
here
so I don't think I'll beat it today no I
I think we still have a pretty good ways
to go
but um we just beat a really cool boss
it was I think it was my favorite boss
so far it took me a couple of hours last
night
and uh
it's funny because
it's funny you start out and you think
that you're done
you guys know if you played the souls
games it's a classic a classic tactic
and you think you're done and then
another one pops out so
but we got that one done Ryan with a
tier one Ryan thank you so much dude
[Music]
why did he lie lore reason
so it's actually a retelling of the
story of Pinocchio I don't know if you
guys knew that or not
but yeah check out my armor
pretty excited about this
Al pal or apple welcome in thank you for
stopping by
so the one kind of bad thing about
getting trying to get the platinum
trophy in this game is that
it has a lot of missable collectibles
and normally on my first playthrough I
do not like playing through
with any sort of guide I mean even if
it's just telling you where the
Collectibles are I don't like playing
like that but unfortunately to avoid
playing like a third time
whoa Bradley Roberts Nathan Mia fourth
quarter okay hold on somebody had to
gift some right there
somebody just gifted out a bunch of Subs
let's see if we can find who it was
Anna
ow okay gotcha very nice Dylan gifting
out five Subs Dylan thank you so much
for gifting those out
appreciate it guys if you just got one
of those gifted subs from Dylan now your
gifted Subs see I'm still used to uh
twitch terminology gifted memberships
there you go Ginny's spamming them in
the chat you unlock all of those emotes
and you get discounted merch uh some
other cool perks as well you can check
out on our community page what's funny
guys is on my TV the way I have it set
up right now whenever you whenever you
guys post our emotes I guess the
PlayStation just doesn't have the code
for those emotes because they're custom
emotes and so it just actually shows out
the full text it doesn't actually show
me the emotes very sad but I can't see
them in the chat though
all right so I am using a guide for
Collectibles so I need to I've already
talked to venini that's this guy right
over here we just brought him to the
hotel
recently so I talked to him and now we
have to fast travel to the Cross City
Hall stargazer
and knock this puppet down a Sawtooth
wheel oh I have to throw a Sawtooth
wheel at the puppet
all right so Croc City Hall Stargazer
that's where we need to go
which should be right here
but uh if you're just wondering General
Impressions so far man like I am I'm
loving this game really really enjoying
the game so far
and the boss man the boss last night I
mean so far I was like okay this is
considerably easier than a Souls game
but that boss last night really ramped
it up a bit
ramped it up for sure okay so I think we
have to go back from here
yeah
walk back there's a bridge over here
I mean but the atmosphere in this game
is just absolutely incredible
you got the planet for uh Lego Harry
Potter Alicia one through four very nice
it's a fun one it is it's a fun one to
do
I enjoyed five through seven more
yeah so that right there we need to
knock it down which I don't think I have
anything equipped right now
to do that
so let's see let's go into our bag here
oh no please tell me I have one there we
go Sawtooth wheel
so let's move that to our equipment
we'll just put it right here in the
middle
so we're basically this is kind of like
a side quest we're looking for these
Clues
oh yeah and I forgot let's see can I
actually start recording as well
dude the PS5 is just that is just
incredible
unless my stream cut out right when I
did that that'd be funny wouldn't it
no but you you can you can stream and
record at the same time all directly
from the PS5 that's that's awesome all
right letter with the refugees address
okay so that is another clue
let's go into our bag here
I also love that it shows you what's new
you get the little indicator there
all right so address Elysian Boulevard
221 B
tells us where that is
so that is the site of the next clue
okay so head back to the Cross City Hall
Stargazer and teleport to inside the
house on Elysian Boulevard Stargazer
okay so that's the next one that we need
to access
and the game like for me it feels like
it might be
I mean I'm running in the frame frame
rate mode
feels like it might be suffering a
little bit every now and then but that
could just be me imagining things too
all right so this one
we need to go to
inside the house on Elysian Boulevard
oh Alicia I was thinking of you the
other day too because there was a
one of these bosses
we we basically started running into
puppet zombies now it's very very
strange Stargazer Tim what's up Tim
welcome in dude
popping in to say hey good luck on the
playthrough don't forget to tap the like
button folks helps the channel yes
indeed Tim thank you for pointing that
out
yes guys if you're enjoying the stream
hanging out this is an impromptu stream
we're streaming straight from the PS5
steel but I can still see your chat
comments Mia welcome in oh this game's
so good
it is so good do you have it already Mia
are you or are you uh kind of thinking
about playing it at some point if you're
on the fence I definitely recommend it
all right I don't need to do anything
with that
I need to go to leave the house cross
the beam the correct doors on your
immediate right before the puppets open
the door and rip the safe open
okay so the reason we're doing this guys
is we're trying to get the platinum
trophy and there are a bunch of missable
collectibles
okay so the question is which
leave the house and cross the beam okay
so there's a beam right there but
there's a there's also a beam over here
across the beam
correct doors on your immediate right
before the puppets okay well let's just
let's just try this one first
you know what maybe it's maybe it's this
right here immediate right it said
before the puppets though and their
puppets in there
all right let's try the other one
yeah so in the first couple levels it's
mostly puppets
but then recently we started getting
introduced to some new enemies which
were
like these bizarre oh wait I think this
is it oh 221B
you used letter with the refugee's
address
the horror quest in Hogwarts right
right
here's the safe that we're looking for
what's inside is it gonna be another
clue oh the owl doctors hunting apparel
and quartz okay so quartz that's an
upgrade material
let's check out the
apparel that we just unlocked so I'll
let I'll see what you guys think I think
by far
this one is the coolest one that I have
so far so we got here's what you start
with actually let me take off the mask
too so you guys can get the let's give
you the full effect here
so there we go with just that's what you
start with the white shirt someone's
memory
that's the second one that we got then
we had the Mad donkeys hunting apparel
that one's kind of cool
but then so far this one was the one
that I liked the best
saviors or survivors hunting apparel and
then we just unlocked this one the owl
doctors hunting apparel the hunting
apparel of the owl doctor it looks
normal yet there is something gruesome
about it I decided to give them Repose
when they were still human this was his
last vow before he got lost before he
lost his ego as a doctor
eh I'm not feeling that one
so far I think that was that was pretty
nice too I think this is my favorite
though followed by that one and then
that one and then the other three are
just whatever
I only have two accessories so far
though the survivor's mask and also the
Mad donkey mask
that was just a little bit too creepy
for me right there
you're not squeamish Dylan but they
should have a warning if you plan to
play that one at night for Hogwarts
right because I mean it's just so it's
so different than anything you've
experienced before
anything in the rest of that game
nothing comes close
all right so we got that we got the owl
uh hunting apparel That's it man we're
ready to proceed to the next uh the next
level and once we get for that we don't
have to
follow the guide quite so much because
you can you can get to the end of a
section and then go back and get
anything you missed so
let's travel to
actually you know what let's see if I do
I have any enough to upgrade oh I
definitely do so I just like last night
when I finished playing
I beat the boss
and you get quite a few of the little
upgrade materials for being the boss so
you'll never see that Quest again
it didn't scare me too much I think
maybe it was because I was playing it on
stream with you guys though that
definitely helps
okay so here's our friend who's gonna
let us upgrade Sophia
and I gotta say dude I am loving
the combat in this game so far
so motivity which is kind of like the
strength attribute
that's what I've been focused on
which is not how I normally play these
games I normally go with some type of
mage
which there's not really any magic in
this game they have something called the
Legion Arts abilities or fable Arts
and those have elemental power so you
can do some electricity some fire
I think I'm just going to go ahead and
put it into there
although it's been really nice having
plenty of Vitality as well yeah let's
just go ahead and focus on getting that
all the way up to 30.
oh I don't like having 4 000 just
sitting there though
let me show you guys some of the weapons
I've made too so you can basically mix
and match when it comes to weapons
so like this weapon right here I took
the blade from my starting weapon
but paired it with the crop police baton
handles you see over there on the right
but then look at some of these weapons
you guys look at this one right here I
took the big pipe wrench handle
and paired it with the booster glaive
which
I really like the booster glaive
unfortunately it's more of a uh a
technique class I believe which is not
what I'm focused on however if I pair it
with this handle
then it makes it much more usable for my
guy
makes it so it's actually worthwhile
what about penny
poor penny
so this one though this one is really
powerful this one's stronger than my
primary weapon
but I'm just not used to the the attacks
are just they're just too slow for me
now maybe there's a boss at some point
that it's going to be worth it to use
them on
watch this
that's the coolest part right there the
Fable art ability
but uh that boss I was fighting last
night I tried this weapon on that boss
for a little bit
and it just wasn't working out it was
too slow so this one is not quite as
strong but
see how much faster I can strike with
this one and it I mean my stamina even
with me striking repeatedly still have
plenty of stamina up there
in the top left
all right so we're totally good with
collectibles
for this point
so let me see if I have any materials
because I'd love to upgrade one more
time instead of having four thousand
and that one's 300 okay so how many do
we need to upgrade one more
how many do we need
oh my gosh we only need five more that's
perfect look at that 4149
Ergo is what we need
so we just need to use one of these
right here
that gives us 300
.
I know everybody's going to compare this
to the souls games
I'll say one area where it is much more
forgiving
is in the ability to recover your lost
souls or Ergo as they call it in this
game Ergo whatever it is
because instead of actually putting it
like in the boss room
they put it to where it's right before
the boss room so it's usually pretty
easy to uh
to get it
cozy games
dude these are my favorite kind of games
though right here not even not even the
scariness of it just the
the the combat the action
some of my favorite things in games all
right so I can never remember which way
I'm pretty sure that's the way that we
entered this area
I wish you guys I should have been
streaming last night man oh my gosh that
boss fight was so good
my favorite boss fight by far
thus far in the game
okay wait is my light on it doesn't seem
like it's yeah I thought it looked like
it was turned off
no house this is uh so we're streaming
from the directly from the PlayStation
5.
which welcome in-house by the way so
this is a much lower quality mic than
what I normally use this is just off of
my um
what is it steel series headset
so it's not bad but I mean going from
the normally I use a Shure sm7b which is
a
broadcast studio quality microphone so
that is the difference
oh man you guys we're going outside now
dude
is that puppet or human
what
path of the pilgrim foggy night
this man I I don't like this
you guys talking about being scared this
is making me very uneasy
all right there comes a new enemy
whoa
okay we can to hit them thankfully
so it's like a dog oh here we go Alicia
remember how I was saying these these
zombie like
dude he's still moving
so we had dogs early in the game but now
this dog it has this weird
blue Spike growing out of it
oh my gosh and there's traps too
no way we've got to worry about traps
now
racket doors that I've done
goodbye
thanks for being here
I wonder if there's any way to disarm
those traps
because I have these I have these things
I can throw but it's I'm trying to lock
on it's not allowing me to lock on all
right so I guess we just have to uh be
on the lookout
oh it definitely worked actually you
know what Dylan let's see dude let's see
if we could see if we could get him to
run into it
okay I love that it that it works on
enemies and not just you
that is hilarious
all right we're gonna have to use that
to our advantage
so here's those zombie
wait are they more are they puppet
zombies or are they just
plain old zombies
what were you guys talking about un
unpacking I don't think I've ever heard
of that game
you guys are trying to get me distracted
so I walk into a trap
we must not walk into the traps
once crot was just a small town on the
coast of little importance
before Elysian Boulevard was built this
place literally was all there was of
crot but when some in the city prospered
they they left the old town behind
through isolation and neglect across
first Incarnation became nothing but
dangerous alleys and I'm gonna let him
finish talking
the bright side I guess the whole city
of Kratz pretty much like that now
the Old Town caught up with the new
true what they say
a receding tide sinks all boats
hmm interesting anybody else getting a
goblet of fire graveyard Vibes right
here
okay investigate a child who was a
blessing to their family lies here may
he rest in peace The Smiling bunny mark
so the marks are
I think these defense Parts here no okay
fiscal damage reduction rate oh I should
put this on right
oh it weighs a lot more but I'm going
with a heavier build character and we
can take it so
the last frame item made by the workshop
Union when the handcrafting workshop
came out with a better item the workshop
Union gave up on its development
but yeah this one is I'm just making
sure I'm looking at the right thing
okay yeah so these weigh less
but this one is more defense
this is called an insulation converter
so the one that I have right here
enhance resistance to electric shock
this one enhances resistance to overheat
yeah that would have been helpful on a
previous boss
this one here enhanced resistance to
Decay that would have been helpful
thoughts before that
this one says can enhance resistance to
status ailments so maybe it's just kind
of an in general
benefit there
so the one I have on right now let's see
if we put this one on I feel like a lot
of the creatures we're running into here
are doing this Decay so I'm going to put
that one on
all right what about this one
cartridge prototype
dude I should have been looking at these
earlier
resistance to shock or resistance to
break
I'm just going to keep this one on for
now
in the defense part oh that's where you
use these things
there's a guy who sells these
but I didn't realize where we were
supposed to use them okay then we have
usable items
I want to find that item I just picked
up
where is it
oh maybe it's a collectible there it is
The Smiling bunny Mark a mark carved
with a smiling bunny that's not creepy
at all it was left in the graveyard of
the mallam district tomb slums The
Smiling bunny is the well-known sign of
the stalkers it is said to serve as a
sort of pass in certain areas
yikes
now what about this little bird you
cannot use this right now what in the
world
tealside welcome in
thanks for stopping by
all right so remember we can't
we can't forget about those traps
only seen one so far haven't we
here's another stargazer
I mean that was pretty close to the last
one
but I'll go ahead and use it anyway
can we open this
no not yet so that's definitely going to
be a shortcut at some point
all right let's continue our Trek
dude I am getting Resident Evil Vibes
right now
Resident Evil 4 anybody
oh this guy's
this guy is not doing well
oh
nice two swipes
star fragment radiant air go fragment
you're a Hufflepuff nice deal side
welcome in my wife is also a Hufflepuff
as is Alicia who is here hanging out in
the chat right now
Tom welcome to the stream Tom yeah I'm
definitely gonna be playing Spider-Man
or sure
I hope to be totally done with this game
by then which I think I will
cause I'm really into this game so
I do want to get the platinum trophy in
this one though and it it requires a
minimum of two full playthroughs
now the bad news is okay there's another
trap the bad news is if I miss any of
those Collectibles that's why I'm using
a collectible guide if I miss any of
them
then it couldn't make it so you need
even more playthroughs
that's why I'm being very careful with
this
what the heck
do you think siblings have to be in the
same house nah I don't think so I think
the Weasleys were probably a
not necessarily the norm
it was just a very interesting
interesting uh example
that's right Dylan yes I knew I knew
there was somebody
Okay so we've got kind of two paths
right here this one is blocked by these
two traps
and then this area over here
this actually looks like where we're
supposed to go probably let's grab
whatever this is right here
what
playing uh gonna be playing Spider-Man I
mean everything they've shown so far the
previews which of course they're
what the heck is that
is that a
dude does that have a bear head
what
what oh my gosh dude
oh my gosh
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we're just
gonna go this way for now
I'm just gonna go over here for a bit
I'm just gonna see what's uh
imagine if I could lead him here and get
him caught in both of those traps though
something to fall from the tree called
it
called it
do we have in here
acidic Crystal spear blade and handle
see what that scales with so if you guys
aren't used to these games or if you've
never played these games before when it
comes to your weapon type basically how
you build your character the attributes
is really about the weapons that you
like to use so I've put a lot of my
stuff into the motivity already which
you see right there the weapon that I'm
using it scales with uh it has a b
scaling so that's good a would be even
better but B is pretty good so like you
see here I don't think we even have
anything oh that's got an A scaling
right there for uh
but so this one right here that one that
we just picked up the acidic Crystal
spear handle and blade
it scales with Advanced well at least it
scales best with the advance
attribute so probably not going to be a
good one for me to use this playthrough
unless I respect my character which
which I could do
but honestly I'm kind of uh I'm liking
liking the play style we've got so far
now one thing about this game is because
they allow you to swap out different
handles
you can actually make it so this one has
the acidic spear handle so if I took the
like the uh the crop police baton handle
which I'm using right now
that would actually improve its scaling
in motivity but it would only go from I
think it would only go from a d to a c
I'll have to double check on that later
um but yeah so you you can make you know
modifications
but yeah I agree
um
who was that Tom yeah Tom was talking
about Spider-Man I agree I think those
Powers look so cool Tom what I've been
trying to figure out because you know
those games always have where you can
explore and do stuff once you beat the
game
like
you would think that Peter's gonna get
rid of the symbiote suit right at some
point in the game
so once that happens then what does that
mean for
the post game stuff right
do they find a way to to have him keep
the powers or does he get something
different or do you like only play as
miles in the post game
oh my gosh that dude
oh my God we gotta go fight it
we have to go fight it
I think so too Alicia I think leading it
to the traps might be a good idea
we're gonna see how fast it is
Dylan am I about to I might be about to
upset you a great deal I I hope not make
sure you're sitting down
I have actually never played the Kingdom
Hearts games never played them oh dude I
knew it was gonna be fast
why didn't he attack he may be friendly
now come on come on up here buddy come
on come come on come on
come on
come on come on keep following keep
following
oh dude this is gonna be great if it
works
yeah yeah come on come on right here oh
I walked over one no
it's okay it's okay it's okay you can
still get him in this one no hey you
come here
this way
oh he's smart he's intelligent
he's not gonna do it
oh wasn't ready for that next swipe
okay come on come on come on
come on come on where is it where is it
at I think I lost it
yeah he doesn't want to be up here at
all
that's why he's just he's just heading
back down
it could be just out of his range but
then he started following me over there
so I don't know
all right let's uh let's actually fight
him for real
okay one two three
okay big one right there oh no
we gotta let our stamina rebuild one
oh my gosh it's that charge
no
could have been really bad
that could have been really bad
wait is he I hear him
oh my gosh there's more oh dude we can
definitely lead him over here I bet
okay hold on make sure we don't
come on come on come on come down here
dude
why do you just turn your back to me
like that
I don't get it
foreign
come on
yes is he actually stuck oh no he it
hurts him but he's not stuck oh he might
be dead we might be dead
we're dead
oh we're we actually got stuck in one
that's a new status I haven't seen that
before break
I don't think we're gonna survive this
don't think we're gonna survive
oh he's on fire
okay
all right now we know how he fights
Jenny have a good one
thanks for stopping by
you guys know what I need to figure out
I need to figure out a way to set up
where I could play on my TV
and still stream with a webcam
excuse me
because
I have my like my TV is so and
especially with the PlayStation 5's
features I mean the fact that it
you know my TV's 4K my monitor's not
I've got hdr on my TV my monitor has HDR
but it's a very poor version of it
I mean first floor problems I know I
know but
it's like why have such a great TV if
when you're playing you can't even play
on it okay so it looks like the traps do
reset
all right
[Music]
oh yeah I know I know I know how to do
it Alicia it's just a matter of
it'd be a very interesting like physical
setup to get it to work
I've had some ideas before you guys know
I love rearranging my office the current
setup is actually the longest I've I
think I've ever had it
oh stop it
foreign
Dylan yeah they they do actually yeah to
your point they do make a a PlayStation
camera as well
how am I not
okay that hits for 467.
dude he's so quick he is so quick
now we got other people to worry about
okay let's just
yeah I'm out of stamina that's not good
and we got two two fighting us okay come
on run for a little bit
why
oh my gosh dude
he's aggressive okay there
oh no
oh we're dead we're
we are so dead
just get all of them
any plans to stream tomorrow
um I mean maybe I don't know why
something special going on
because honestly I didn't even plan to
stream today but
I don't know I just started uh I started
playing on my
TV sometimes I move my PS5 around like
I'll move it to my desk where you guys
normally see me streaming from
and then I'll also play play some on my
TV and I just use the uh in PS5
recording feature
to record my gameplay
oh my gosh it's your birthday tomorrow
no way happy early birthday to Alicia
everybody
21 right I think that's what you were
saying the other day
tomorrow is try wizard Tuesday
come near you all right so we can't
basically we know we can't
skip enemies
because then when we try to run a
retreat they're all going to be going
crazy
okay I'm gonna try not to use there's my
health right there
yeah let's go and fight you
and then there's another guy right there
or dog creature whatever
and then I think it's the I think the
bear is the only one left after that
gotcha
all right so let's go ahead and heal
now here's one cool thing we can do Anna
welcome in
how's it going Anna we are streaming
live from our PS5 today
so that's why we've got no Cam and the
difference in mic quality look at this I
like set my weapon on fire
oh and he does not like that
see when I don't perfectly block that
it just completely destroys my
Poise so all my stamina is completely
broken yes we set him on fire nice he's
gonna start taking damage over time
that's good here have some more
see right there I perfectly I did a
perfect guard so
oh
no no no don't slam again don't slam
again
heal we got a heal we got to heal come
on come on do it
respawn
imagine if he respawns some of the like
sort of uh larger enemies
I think he would be considered a mini
kind of like a mini boss
come on heal
yes let's go well it wasn't pretty but
we got it done Fable Catalyst shot put
and a star fragment
all right now let's go test our Theory
we're gonna go
we're gonna go up to our Stargazer we're
gonna rest because we have no heels and
then we're gonna see if he if he comes
back
so if he comes back we are not fighting
him again
we are definitely not fighting him again
the sound is off like with the game or
you just mean my mic because yeah it's
it's like my uh
it's just the mic from my gaming headset
so it's not nearly as as good as my my
usual
all right so full heel
crunchy Auto
yeah if you if you uh get in like this
yeah it's really it'll actually if I
move it back from my face
is that is that better or worse right
there I moved it away from me
check check one two one two
gaming headsets man they're top quality
top top-notch quality
okay we got the traps over there let's
go ahead and fight you
completely missed that
better but lower yeah that's what I
figured so we need like a we need like a
good middle ground kind of like
where it's close enough
but also uh
oh my gosh he actually comes back oh
no way dude
yeah okay here's what we're gonna do
maybe that's why they give you this
branching path here
it can be like yeah I don't want to
fight this guy every time
so instead of fighting him every time
what we're gonna do is we're just gonna
go under
go around
we beat him once that's all that matters
we got the items from it
okay he's going back up so we're gonna
head this way
and hope that we don't run into about
four or five of those
oh
whenever that happens that means there's
a
one of these butterflies that you can
oh where is it where is it where is it I
heard it but I don't see it
we're looking for a little red there it
is
no
why'd it disappear
I have to turn my lamp back on no who
are you
okay heal
turn our lamp back on
oh I think we lost it
I think we took too much time
because you only have so long
to take them out
dang it
maybe we could go back and get it to
spawn again
the tomb slums entrance
dude this is so Resident Evil
I mean this this feels like Resident
Evil 4.
yeah let's draw you out
and let's be honest bloodborne too
oh that one's bigger I just now realized
that
I need to get rid of you
[Music]
oh we got we need to hit that one
with this right here come on yes
should take him out
or be very close
all right let's go
okay
whoa who are you
oh my gosh I thought they all came out
who else is hiding in here
anybody else
oh man this is a big area
got all these rooftops over here
okay looks like there's more over here
too
Shield up
in this case sword
oh this looks like
that really looks like that should be
breakable right there
okay that's where we came in
and then all right I guess that's it so
let's go this way
I knew I heard them
is there another one
this dude losing his mind over here
why can I never tell if
if it's on or not
okay I just need to start looking at the
little icon because it's much easier to
see
on the icon
oh do you see how she was moving
what the heck
that was some strange movement right
there
the human back not supposed to move that
way
oh look at this one over here it's a
little item
wanted black rabbit Brotherhood
a criminal group of four stalkers
charged with theft assault tampering
with bodies and other serious crimes
their base is the mallam district so be
extremely careful
when entering it
all right it's not gonna
lock me out of anywhere if I drop down
is it at least I hope not
oh come on where are you at I hear you
I hear you back there
oh my God this is gracious
oh my gosh that's where we needed the
webcam right there that's that's where
we needed the webcam
holy smokes
no no no no no not like this not like
this
we barely dented him
he doesn't like the fire
back up
I don't see us beating this guy
run away run away
gonna awaken like five other enemies
I'm just hoping that we'll make it to
another Stargazer that's just this is an
old uh Dark Souls trick ladies and
gentlemen
is he still following us
hobbler's Bridge
on a rainy night no
just need to make it to another
Stargazer oh no there's another one
I think he stopped following though
I actually think he stopped following
the bad news is we still did not come to
stargazer
and we have no heels
okay we do need to do this
saw blade that's it that's all that's
down here
no way that's all you can do down here
now how do we get over here
thank you
nope
yeah I don't want to get too close to
that because that's gonna
wake him up
wait really
okay wait maybe right here
there's the path
of vivid Ergo fragment okay
all right I don't know what to do man
we know there's another one of those
in the opposite direction
I'm pretty sure if we get too close to
that he is busting out of there
uh
yeah yeah yeah yeah Retreat Retreat
retreat
okay well we confirmed he does indeed
bust out of there
I don't think it's the same one I
definitely think it's a different one we
backed all the way up perfect okay
so let's go back this way and hopefully
the one that we initially ran into over
here hopefully he Retreats back to his
original location
honestly do but even if he does I don't
know I don't know what the solution is
oh
basically lost souls what do you mean
like uh very similar to Dark Souls
yeah it is it is very similar to the
souls games
say so so the story is is a retelling of
Pinocchio
oh no don't die to this guy
it's a retelling of Pinocchio
and the combat is is so so very
souls-like though yeah
I would say if he took Pinocchio
bloodborne and then a little bit like
like a little bit of Bioshock as well
because I don't know if you ever played
Bioshock but there's with this world
it's you're clearly in a place that
is not what it once was it was um
the way that Society had previously
lived and there's all this sort of like
interesting Dynamics between puppets and
how the puppets have
they were created by Geppetto to help
humans
but have instead ended up just
going crazy they call it in-game they
call it the puppet Frenzy
now that looks like an area that we can
explore over there okay I'm also
concerned that we haven't ran into our
buddy yet
oh I hear him though
I hear him
there he is
okay so the question is
oh my gosh look at that we barely did
any damage to him
can we sneak up on him and get a big hit
right away
because I think we have to fight him
like I don't see any other option
Rod welcome in oh dude I love them I
love them
uh Dark Souls
is one of my favorite games of all time
as is Elden ring as is bloodborne the
order changes on any given day
it really does
you started falling from the Hogwarts
Legacy videos but uh Eliza piece your
game of the year oh that's awesome dude
yeah I'm uh so I just beat the
Archbishop boss last night if you're
already on New Game Plus and you
probably have a pretty good idea of
where I'm at in the game but
specifically right now I'm in I'm in
trouble because
I'm out of health and I ran into this
crazy enemy right here
so I'm trying to figure out I mean we
might be able to kind of cheese this
because it looks like he is not gonna
cross that last spot right there
oh my gosh he's still got a hit in on us
all right let's see let's see will he
ever cross through here
oh oh my gosh he totally does
but I still think if I run far enough
away yeah he eventually turns back
so he definitely doesn't want to be
I mean if I had any health I would just
I would just fight him but
given our current circumstances
I think we're gonna have to uh
bring a little cheese into this
the last three story bosses are insanely
hard oh man
I'm going for the platinum trophy though
so I'll have to play it through at least
twice
go on back up there
no
yeah back up
is he gonna come all the way through
yes he is
there's our answer
oh my gosh let's run let's run let's run
let's run let's run no I shouldn't I
should have just fought him
uh
uh fourth quarter I don't think so no I
think we still have quite a ways to go I
don't think we'll beat it today
so Rod tell me this where so the boss
that I just fought the uh the Archbishop
or whatever
it's kind of like a two-phase boss you
think it's just a Big Blob and then
you have this other part where he's got
like the tail but there's
sort of not the tail
where would where would that one rank
because that one took me that one took
me a little bit and definitely the
hardest boss by far
but I have a feeling they're gonna get
even harder than that
oh man so we've gotta we've got to
really perfect this this run through
this area right here I've been being a
little too LAX
oh wow I just realized I don't have any
of my I tried Fable arts and
that's one of the easiest ones oh I knew
it
I knew it
I mean hopefully I'll be better at the
game by then too
taking too many hits even on this part
right here
wait where's the bear
where oh there he is okay
all right let's just go around
no stop it come on
foreign
oh my goodness that's the first time
he's ever done that
never done that the whole time I've been
playing
what in the world
went in break your character's HP
Recovery through pulse cells immediately
decreases use a purification
I don't even know how to say that word
impul and pool
to remove status ailments
yeah I thought that was our first time
getting hit by that
all right well now we know he can do
that
yeah it definitely it definitely started
to click with that boss Rod like
once you you feel so
you just feel so powerful once you
figure out the pattern
and you're just hitting that perfect
guard on everything
like that
perfect guard so when you hit those oh
there's there's nothing more satisfying
I kind of wish they had a repost attack
but maybe that's something I'm gonna get
later on
all right so he's right there
I don't even know how he like
what made him start coming after me so
he had to come through this area right
here
oh
you following me again not this time
okay
no he's just Out Of Reach
okay he's going back up let's wait for
it
all right
oh man
this is a tough section
so we have to get through all of that oh
yeah yeah yeah so I can do this now okay
this should be over here
no stop stop
no quit quit quit
I'm gonna lose it again
where'd he go
we lost him
uh I need to figure out a way to draw
out those enemies before I start
oh geez that's right there's all these
guys too
hello
oh and yeah TL side your question no
there there is there's no one hit in
this game unfortunately
definitely one hit for you as the player
getting hit by their stuff
all right
oh no come on
oh I can't get it back to back
oh here we go
so we have to get through that guy we
have to get through all of the little
regular guys we have to get by the bear
in order to get to this next big guy up
here and having any decent amount of
Health at all
that
is going to be a bit of a challenge
okay
what's after the big guy another big guy
he's waiting for us at the end of a gate
because the first thing I try to do was
run by them all and just see if I could
uh
oh wait did I never get that oh no
because that's when he he busts out when
we do this next part
that's a good call Sunburst yeah we we
recognize some places already where we
thought oh wait did we go down this way
hold on might be exactly what you're
talking about here
there was a place early in the game
where or early in this level where I
said ooh that's definitely going to be a
shortcut later
start my recording again
okay so we can we can get back up here
let's go down this see where this leads
oh oh my gosh sunburst
let's go
no that isn't I thought that would
thought that would for sure open okay
wait maybe this is still a shortcut
though maybe maybe
was that a little uh hidden area right
there maybe
yes
scribbles of Slum resident everything
changed after the doctor spread the blue
medicine I buried my brother I don't
even know I don't even know it was my
brother who is The Doctor Who's blue
hair is it in his Cane
interesting
all right that was huge though
great timing on that Sunburst great
timing
yes now we're gonna be able to skip a
large portion of that
get her health back right there
um
yeah it's going back down just trying to
think if there's anything else I wanted
up there
I could probably go and upgrade another
another uh level if I wanted to
but let's proceed a bit more okay so
that one
that is going to be a shortcut later
pretty sure
now where does this even put me out at
though that's the question
okay right right there is where Big
Boy's gonna come flying out
okay so let's ignore him for now
try and put that off as long as we can
get rid of all these enemies
okay that's a dead end right there
we already went in here that's where the
elevator is okay
got the ladder right there
okay let's see if I hug this right wall
is he still gonna come flying out
you need the slum Shack key oh
hmm yeah he's gonna compline out
all right I think this is a decent area
to fight him though let me look over
here
oh wait a second you know what oh my
goodness dude I
I got a legion arm
specifically for a scenario such as this
Rod or anybody else who's played the
game I don't know if you guys oh I
forgot about that little shortcut or
whatever that uh little secret spot
there is a legion arm that allows you to
set these traps
switch Legion arm okay so it is this one
right here deus ex machina and it scales
with motivity yes
that is the build I've been going for
all right so
when the landmine is buried in the
ground it explodes upon enemy detection
originally this explosive device was
created to blast Bedrock once used by
laborer puppets it has been repurposed
as a butcher of Puppets armors
all right so I only have the first tier
right now though
um
dude look what you can upgrade it to
though better enemy detection increases
number of installation and then
increases the detection range and
explosion range all right let's see how
much damage it does to this guy
I think I can only plant one right now
but we'll we'll try and set up as many
as we can
oh I forgot again
all right I'm doing this right now
otherwise I'm just gonna keep forgetting
see if we can roll right
there
yes
Dark Moon Moonstone of the Covenant
that's actually a really good one
use that for upgrading
oh yeah now see we're rip okay
come on
the one with the Rope is op really
the one with the shield is good too see
I almost had completely written off the
one with the Rope because like there's
no way that's gonna be good against like
really tough enemy bosses and stuff
I haven't even I should have read and
see what it does the more you upgrade it
all right so there's our ladder which is
what gives us the shortcut spot
okay
let's go over here let's lay some of
these mines
okay that's one
I can do at least two all right
all right that's it
oh come on one already exploded
okay it did 348.
not crazy
oh my gosh the timing he is so fast
sheesh
I'm just fighting him now though now
that we've got the shortcut
yeah I gotta be much faster
there we go
what I'm just standing here he keeps
missing
oh come on
oh
[Music]
what what
bro oh we actually launched all the way
over there
oh I was too early I knew I was too
early
I'll take that
come on dude give me the
foreign
sorry we wouldn't have beat him anyway
oh we blocked three of the four
oh let's go
let's go
oh come on
oh that last one
foreign
oh we actually can heal
he just hit three in a row you gotta be
kidding me
oh let's go I can't believe we got it
again not pretty
but I'll take it
dude and we got the key to open this now
that was awesome
oh great
I don't think I should fight this guy
right now should I all right I'm gonna
run I'm gonna run I'm gonna run I'm
gonna go back to the Stargazer
yeah we've got six six thousand six
twenty eight we might need to uh
go ahead and use that
and I don't know maybe I'll end up using
this later
but right now
I'm kind of like eh
doesn't do quite as much damage as I'd
like to see now you know what on the
smaller guys that might
that might uh take them out
truly we can get five nah teal side I
don't like to ask for memberships or
anything
appreciate you guys just being here and
hanging out it means a lot and uh Dylan
no yeah I have never played the Kingdom
Hearts games
any of them never played any of them
all right let's go ahead and teleport
back
to the hotel oh wait we got a couple
people interested to talk with us
looks like vanini I think
oh my goodness Dylan you didn't have to
do that Dylan Dylan already gifted
gifted out five memberships earlier
Dylan just gifted out five more to our
community here
Dylan thanks so much for doing that man
uh looks like Abby the artist Craig
Craig what's up dude Andrew Young as
well
Umbra
cadbane Andrew
oh wait I'm seeing these double for some
reason
congrats guys welcome to house wrecking
tour courtesy of Dylan
enjoy your emotes you get access to
those now
even Priceless things have a price
every item is a treasure of
distinguished quality zodiac what's up
welcome in
request appraisal of Collectibles this
is new and did I also see Mr Keys over
here as well
Chris Keyes podcast I knew I recognized
the logo though welcome in dude
all that that smiling bunny Mark
remember we picked that up earlier
it's just the mark of the black rabbit
Brotherhood a notorious band of stalkers
the stalkers has a unified Force cease
to be after their defeat at the Battle
of the workshop Tower
the black rabbit Brotherhood took over
the Marlin District after that
I believe you could use this Mark to
move safely whilst on the black rabbit
brotherhood's Turf to use their
unsophisticated vernacular and give you
entree to the black market as well
but be careful sir
the black rabbit Brotherhood is quite
Infamous for how they treat Interlopers
if they catch you they'll put you in the
Liar's coffin
yes the Liar's coffin is as unpleasant
as it sounds
ah and I see we have new physical
records to catalog for the collection
such effort deserves commensurate reward
don't you think
oh Crescent moonstone
even
see what he's got for sale yeah this
thing right here
[Music]
an inner layer
that reduce or that absorbs physical
damage reduces damage from slash attacks
this one reduces damage from piercing
this one reduces damage from Strike
they all weigh the same
hey zodiac appreciate you stopping by
dude have hope you have a good uh have a
good Monday good class
yeah I I and speaking of the YouTube
stream it was just a kind of a spur of
the moment thing I'm actually streaming
straight from my PS5 I'm playing Liza P
for
for the channel because I want to do a
I'm doing trophy hunts for it
and I'll make a video on that eventually
but
I remembered hey PS5 has the ability to
stream built in let's just test that out
and see how it goes so that's why the
mic doesn't sound nearly as good if you
guys are wondering Workshop unions based
armor liner yeah I'm gonna try this one
and you know what let's just go and buy
all these they're only 500.
because now we can
if we go into our equipment right here
so the one that we have currently
[Music]
yeah it weighs
weighs a less but it's kind of just the
basic one the one you start with so it's
I'm looking at the numbers over there
four slash so four three five
this one's gonna be seven three almost
five
oh wow so they're basically a reduction
in everything
except for the one that you're building
toward and they weigh more hmm
I actually don't know if I want to put
any of those on
now that one I'm gonna put on because
we're in an area right now that is all
about the break
oh and it also is making us slightly
heavy
is weight just off of equipped gear not
inventory right yeah yeah so
I'm pretty sure it's so it's obviously
it's your weapon it's these little uh
frames right here so this is what this
kind of like builds your
defense physical damage reduction
and then this converter which these are
sort of like I don't know I kind of
think of them as amulets but then I
think there's actually a separate one
for amulets too
these cartridges also factor into it
and you know what it may although those
actually have weight on them too the
legion arms
which I didn't really love that one so
let's go ahead and change that back
the uh the flam flamberg right there had
been doing really well for us
puppets drink so this one right here Rod
who's beating the game a couple times
already Rod was saying that this one is
really good let's read this here
all right so we know about the first one
can be strung around an enemy to drag it
towards you or move you toward it then
the second ability is press and hold the
legion arm button to track an enemy
what does that mean exactly track an
enemy
uh dot enables Dodge after hit
and then attack link if you pull or wire
trace an enemy and press and hold the
legion arm button it will trigger a link
attack oh interesting
Keys you're in the factory area looking
for venini oh yeah
slightly heavy figuring stuff out yeah
so if you're
if you are going it depends on the type
of build you're going for too I would
say
so that one's
eight five seven nine the four minutes
scales really good with my motivity but
you know what I'm gonna put that one
back on I'm gonna see if I can
do any better with that one
because I did unlock the second one
but Rod you were saying the last upgrade
yeah that sounds interesting I feel like
it's one of those that I unless I I need
to see it so I need to like look up a
video or something to actually see it in
practice
and then you were saying the shield one
right here too this one
so that one's got pretty hefty weight on
it as well oh but it does scale nicely
with my motivity which is what my build
is focused on
foreign
arm
that can block enemy attacks with your
left arm when it receives a blow the
embedded device explodes oh that does
sound nice can make weapon attacks while
guarding
oh it's just like a shield
oh dude I could see that being really op
guard Perry when when the Fable slot
remains you can Parry by pressing the
Fable button
wait what
when the Fable slot remains do you still
have to time it though
it looks like in a little video it looks
like they're still timing it but
counter charge while performing a guard
counter charge for a more powerful
attack
okay so this one do I have to hit
wait guard Perry here let me watch
closely
I wonder if you have to hit triangle
like just when they're attacking you
oh yeah you can see it here you're right
or wait where do I go
switch Legion arm
it's a timed fairy okay gotcha
modify here's where we could see it
because I already have that one unlocked
puppet string
what
oh my goodness
that looks crazy okay so he like
okay now this one enables dodging after
a hit okay so that's pretty
straightforward
well I don't know what it means by track
does he just lunge toward it
[Music]
you feel like they nerfed the big cop at
City Hall from the demo
you couldn't beat him in the demo beat
him second try and hey maybe you just uh
you got good Mr Keys No I I think they
actually made the Mad donkey boss I
think they made that boss a bit harder
because in the demo he was incredibly
easy to backstab
I mean he was so easy to backstab I was
backstabbing him like crazy and you you
can still backstab him quite a bit even
now but I felt like they made it at
least a little bit harder
Rod what was your build by the way were
you focused mainly on
motivity technique or Advance because
I've been going almost solely motivity
right now both my technique and my
Advance are really really low I'm kind
of sad though because this booster
glaive weapon I feel like would be super
fun to use
and I don't have it I've got it right
now set up with the uh
the pipe as the handle
which makes it scale better with with my
attributes but
[Music]
he kills you more than big cop yeah
I beat him first try in the demo and in
the
I think he beat me once in the
[Music]
in the actual game Fox boy welcome in
motivity then change to technique the
better weapons in the game scale with
technique oh that's what I was kind of
afraid of
for the long term I mean I'm doing well
so far but
yeah I did hear you can respect later so
what do you what was your favorite
technique weapon do I have it yet I've
already unlocked a couple of the boss
weapons but Fox boy welcome in
it is going well so far going well we
are
probably not quite to the halfway point
of the game
kind of just uh chatting right now and
talking about weapons and such
investigating the puppet frenzy and it
looks like I need your help
first let me show you a little something
I've been working on
I call it the Ergo wavelength decoder
that's interesting
I assure you it works
my suspicions are correct
something in the pub is very Ergo is
causing their aggression
my decoder can find malicious signals
within the waves but cannot possibly get
close enough to gather the Ergo wave
records myself
you on the other hand hmm would you
could you
I I refuse to believe the king of
Puppets is truly behind this this puppet
Rampage
it's too simple but also a bit too much
even for him
suspect the Ergo itself is corrupted or
at least compromised
I do so desperately want to find the
cause as I'm sure you do too my friend
it breaks my heart to see puppets turned
into murderous tools of bloodshed
the Ergo wavelength decoder you're
always welcome friend
[Music]
all right
Keys you'd never played a soul type game
before
oh dude once you play one oh man you're
good
you're gonna be so into it so you
haven't have you gotten to any
okay let's see you're doing okay now
donkey killed you three times
so a lot of the the hardcore Souls
players we don't like to use any of the
when you make it to the big bosses they
each have a little point in front of
them I can't remember what they are in
this game but there's there's a little
uh spot where you can summon in help
now I don't know how powerful the
summons are in this game
but I've always kind of made of a point
I like to try and do it without summons
people always get on these games so like
they don't have an easy mode I'm like
well you can make it easier by using
using summons Eldon ring took it up a
notch even more by giving you the
ability to uh
oh what did they call those things
because you had your your people you
could sum it in but then you had the
other I can't remember the name of them
but
the mimic tier was one of the best ones
so like but what I'm going to tell you
Keys ignore those purists who are like
don't use summons use your summons
especially just starting out and
learning the game because it's going to
make it a much more enjoyable experience
for you then if you love The Games
enough and you want to go back
then you can say like all right I'm
gonna I'm gonna give myself a little bit
I'm gonna make it harder this time
and try to do it without the summons
but uh you'll get it man you'll get it
and and there's nothing like it's just
it's so satisfying I think that's one of
the biggest things
that's one of the biggest things that
hooks me anyway is that sense of
satisfaction that you get I think I'm
gonna put one into Vitality here
because now it sounds like I might end
up respecting later based on our chat
with Rod here
Fox boy this game really piqued your
interests and you want to get it it's
pretty awesome dude I'm enjoying it a
lot so far
I highly recommend it it's kind of
amazing that it just came from uh at
least to me an unknown developer I don't
know that they've really any done any
big games before
and to come out with something like of
this quality it's just it's pretty
insane really
see what weapon were you saying Rod
let's see here the uh the puppet Ripper
do I have that yet
no I don't
have etiquette I have seven coil springs
sword
I have holy sword of the Ark
acidic Crystal spear
puppet Ripper no I don't have that one
and when you do get it rod do you uh mix
and match the handle or anything or do
you just keep the default
actually with the if it's like a boss
weapon I guess you can't
do it anyway
yes Spirit ashes that's right that's
right
[Music]
a mobile game Studio made it what I
don't think I even realized that they
were a mobile game Studio
yeah this right here though I don't I
don't really see the great benefit of
doing this maybe I'll change my mind
later but
don't see the benefit at the moment all
right I think there was one more person
I was supposed to talk to Geppetto Maybe
no I do want to go up there though
because I think I have
think I can upgrade our P organ
wait
sorry I was trying to look at chat and
also walk walk at the same time
Fox boy you played uh Dark Souls 3
bloodborne Fallen order and Jedi
Survivor yeah if all in order the Jedi
games they're they're sort of like in
that vein
they definitely take inspiration from
The Souls games
I wouldn't call them I wouldn't I don't
know if I'd call them a Souls like which
is the term that a lot of people use
oh yeah we've got two of these
all right rod what are your what are
your thoughts on on the P organ upgrades
here
which once I've made these oh I don't
think I can go back can I yeah you can't
go back and change anything
[Music]
you get it by killing one of the harder
bosses can't change the handle okay
gotcha
like the idea of going first try to
without so you can see yeah that's true
that's true Keys you could do that
oh yeah because it does cost resources
you're right you're right
you are correct
more cells wait what do you mean by more
more cells
rod
for the uh the pulse cell yeah I all
right good I went with that one on this
I went with more pulse cells and I did
increase the staggerable window
here we had add Fable slots and we had
the link Dodge I don't really see myself
using Dodge too much in this game
because of how much they emphasize the
parrying or not the parrying the uh
perfect guard
healing cells yeah yeah yeah nice that's
what I went with
so is it the same thing every time up
here we have Rising Dodge enables
dodging when on the ground
increase your cells again
retain guard regain one retains a
certain amount of guard regain when
receiving damage
or add amulet slots increases the number
of amulet equivalent slots
oh
I feel like definitely this one again
increase the pulse cells
and then I'm I'm toying between these
two
how much is the game going for you mean
this game it's still brand new so if
you're on Xbox it's free or well if a
Xbox game pass that is it's free for
Game Pass
but um I doubt they've ran any sales on
it yet for PS5 so it's probably the full
70 still
all right so let's do this one
[Music]
oh that's so interesting so once I've
done it once on another one
you can't keep like stacking it
enhance his weapon attack when
durability is at maximum
enhance his weapon attack when dish
discharged
enhances perfect guard destruction ooh I
feel like that's the one
I feel like that's the one
get the first skill for the Dodge you're
gonna need it for late game the double
dodge wait so can I can I still go back
and get stuff on here
oh I can
why did I think for some reason I
thought I could only do two
okay
all right so you said get the first
skill for the Dodge you're gonna need it
for late game the double dodge this one
right here the link Dodge enables
another Dodge in the middle of the Dodge
motion
oh man there's so many little
so many things to consider
enhance fatal Attack One enhance fatal
Arts attack
enhance Ambush stagger
[Music]
lowers guard regain reduction one lowers
damage
weight lowers damage
oh lowers the damage received during
charge attack and when using Fable Arts
enhanced attribute resistance like see
that's kind of a good one that's just
you don't really have to worry about
building your character that way it's
just going to automatically apply
yeah I believe it does have multiple
endings Fox boy I think well I know you
have to play through the game at least
twice to get the platinum trophy so
perfect guard Fable charge enhance one
charge is Fable when perfect guard is
successful
increase weapon durability recovery
speed
lower Legion consumption in a crisis on
your HP is low reduces stamina
consumption from Dash
lowers the weapon durability consumption
for Ambush attacks
oh my gosh there's so much to consider
magazine effect enhance increase Ergo oh
that could be super useful
but I feel like you're going to hit a
point where you're not going to really
need more
there go
Greece's consumable possession increases
throwable object possession
oh this one right here
special grindstone increase the effect
duration I want to be able to increase
that yes
yep yep yep yep yep yep
going with that for sure
all right now let's go ahead and go up
here
and I'm gonna do
oh I just read it I read it I read it
this one perfect guard destruction
[Music]
definitely want to focus on that
seeing how important the perfect guards
are
yeah Rod I did I did see that in the in
the trophy guide so I've been I've been
doing all lies for this playthrough
you need two quarts to unlock Sunburst
yeah so like once you um
actually that's a good question do I
unlock the link oh I did yeah I kind of
screwed that up didn't I
because I need to uh I just need to wait
till I get more quartz then I'll be able
to come and drop one here
yeah I think you're right I think I have
to do two
because see how that one's lit up there
well we'll know because we'll see if I
have more pulse cells actually
yeah I don't so you're you're totally
right you have to actually
spin two on there which I probably
should have done but it's fine
it's fine shouldn't take me too long to
find another quartz
okay is there anything else I wanted to
do in here
I don't think so I think we're good
all right
the question is is that dude I don't
think the big guys are gonna come back
it'd be crazy if they did though
wouldn't it
would be insane
we know for sure there's already another
one at the end of this little area
though that I'm at remember if you guys
were still here the one behind the gate
we know for sure we're going to run into
him
all right elevator down
oh actually you know what you know what
you know what you know what we should go
back to the top
because we
we need to get that that butterfly
actually do butterfly butterflies might
give you
is it quartz they give you
so the key is we need to take out all
those enemies
the next bosses of pain oh boy
oh wait this is the wrong way going the
wrong way sorry sir please don't follow
me
just turn around
just go back to your own business
foreign
[Music]
now I want to get to it even even more
I want to try to play it on stream today
oh when it it appears again oh I didn't
realize that I thought it was just gone
oh
yeah
please don't follow me bear I should
have looked I didn't even look
see where he was
okay right right here in this area
okay I'm gonna take you out first
all right it usually spawns oh oh
take you out
okay right in here there it is
oh I don't think we got it
where'd he go
okay so Rod said they'll it spawns again
okay my lights still
where are you
where there he is nice
oh Dark Moon of moonstone of the
Covenant okay so not quartz that's fine
we needed to get that anyway all right I
don't want to go back that way because
all sorts of enemies attack you there
just gonna run by the bear
oh come on
uh Wilmer welcome in yeah it's it's a
really fun game I'm enjoying it a lot so
far
I mean if you've liked any of the other
Souls games it's it's an easy easy
recommend as I go the wrong way that's
bad
please don't follow me just go go just
go back you're good
you're good just just go back
he went back guys I think you listened
actually
all right let's heal
and honestly even if you don't like the
souls games this might be a game that
could get you into it I will say the
story is is much easier to follow
than what the souls games typically try
to do
much easier to follow
and I mean it is also a story that many
of us
at least uh Pinocchio is a story that
many of us are familiar with
all right you're probably gonna drop
down aren't you
come on
jump down
all right do the big boys come back
we're about to find out
let's see
no they do not thank goodness
shoo because those guys are tough okay
so here's where we we left off we opened
this door right here
but then I didn't want to go in and
fight because I was so low
I can tell you this uh Sunburst without
spoiling anything
so I've been using a collectible guide
to try and make sure that I
don't miss anything you know
about 40 percent Rod that that is that's
what I was gonna say because the game is
broken up into chapters
hold on let me look this up here and I
can tell you really quick
so if I hit the collectible guide here
chapter so yeah I am I am in chapter
five right now
and they're 11 total chapters
and I mean you can do the math but then
you also think about the game's probably
going to get harder so we're definitely
still in like the first
first third of the game probably
all right so is that it is that all we
do in here
just open that up
nice okay
I really wish there was something like
bloodborne and the souls games I mean
maybe there will be later
like an amulet or something that would
increase my
health over time oh that increases my
weight limit reduces weapon durability
consumption I could probably take that
the max HP went off honestly
because what is what is my HP at right
now
character info
okay we're at 533 HP right now
what does that drop us to
4.99
yeah I'm I'm in uh chapter five yeah so
this one is called
what is it called here
the path of the pilgrim
4.99
I mean honestly the I think I'll change
it back the weapon durability hasn't
been too big of a problem so far
as long as you're keeping an eye on it I
mean they're having a couple boss fights
when I've had to
run off and use it
in the middle of the fight
all right so we know
we've got another big boy at the end
all right
oh I saw you still moving thought you
might be alive
there's an amulet for that nice it's
always so slow in the souls games but
what it does is it prevents you from
having
it prevents you from having to like like
right now I don't want to heal I don't
want to waste that heel
because it's not enough to justify in my
opinion but if I had like an amulet or
something like that it'd be nice oh you
said it's not very good though that's
unfortunate
[Applause]
oh I didn't expect that little lunge
attack there okay now it makes sense to
use it for sure
all right let's make sure we take out
all these enemies I don't think there's
any more
all right buddy let's do this
well this is this guy might be different
he is different
oh that shock actually did really nice
no come on come on come on come on get
up
this guy's more like the bear
his move set
it's kind of crazy isn't it oh he's
Shish
yeah I just I don't know how to fight
this guy
I don't know how to fight you
I can't read him I can't read him at all
I'm stuck I'm dead
I'm dead
yeah Sunburst I haven't looked up too
much on that how how the new game plus
works
Rod said you get better versions of
Defense Parts way more Ergo to level up
yeah I do know that the the trophy guide
that I'm using they recommend for your
first playthrough that
because with your with your boss souls I
know they're not souls in the game but
I'm gonna call them Souls your boss
souls you don't want to use those you
definitely don't want to use them just
for Souls
you can you can turn them in for amulets
or weapons and so on your first
playthrough they recommend doing all the
weapons
so I'm not getting any of the boss
amulets on my first run through
so I'll have to get those on my second
one
dude that shock actually did pretty well
against him
if I could have capitalized on it
the problem with that guy I just
I've only seen that's the first time
I've seen him I just can't tell when
he's about to strike
I don't know when to block
oh
Daniel welcome in no I've not beaten the
game I'm about
40 percent of the way through the first
playthrough to get the trophy we're
gonna have to play through multiple
times
oh my gosh he gets on you so much faster
than you think
oh geez
he doesn't
I think okay so he's got the charge
attack
that's attack number one
right there
and that hits what three times
and he's got the little swipe
he's got this
just kind of just like another charge
oh let's go oh we can't get to his front
that's okay though
foreign
let's go
let's go let's go let's go
so say if an enemy drops Quartz in new
game do they drop another new game plus
Ross said yes ah very nice very nice
all right as per usual the first time
going through these guys it's not it's
not always pretty chat
but hey we got the job done and we're
moving on
okay I'm just a little I mean a little
extra cautious now because
I feel like there should be another
Stargazer coming up soon or
oh
[Music]
hold on I want to listen to what he says
a nasty puppet has invaded our territory
be careful
something tells me that's the boss that
Rod was teasing a bit earlier
any hidden areas like Dark Souls maybe
maybe
nope nope how about here
how about here
all right I didn't get to read that
letter that we picked up
oh this is that thing that uh
venini gave us
this device finds errors in the grand
Covenant imprinted on the puppets vanini
decided to analyze the puppet's Ergo
wavelengths to determine the cause of
the puppet frenzy you should be able to
collect quite a number of Records while
getting rid of the puppets all over crop
okay
hey welcome in
mukison moccasin
sorry if I'm mispronouncing that
thank you for stopping by what do you
think a Harry Potter type game
like this would be like oh that's a fun
thing to think about
man a Harry Potter souls-like game
well I think they would have to do
something it would have to be more
ranged combat so they'd have to look at
something like probably like Remnant
which I haven't played but I know what
people have described as like a Souls
game but with guns
scribbles of the slum resident okay
that's not the one we just picked up
this one maybe
sweepers branch office newspaper
archives
join the group as an apprent stalker
it's been reported multiple times for
ignoring ranks and neglecting Duty
caught being in contact for the past
year with the fox a bastard stalker
under investigation for leaking inside
Secrets but has not responded yet
so the bastards that's like a group of
stalkers
as it is with a bastard she is assumed
to have been ousted from Noble
succession the interesting thing is she
claims that
a cat is a bastard of the family so in
other words her lost sibling if the
information above is reliable the cat is
possibly a spy from the bastards it's an
unofficial interrogation so there are no
restrictions to the methods available
I don't really know what I just read
there but something about a cat
oh man
all right I think we read the one I
think that was the one we just picked up
yeah we definitely read that one already
okay hopefully we're getting to a
stargazer at some point here shortly
because
we are low again
oh yeah we're out of that too
remin is awesome you enjoy rod yeah I've
heard I've heard very good things
about both the first one and I mean
especially the second one I feel like
I've been seeing that everywhere lately
okay I think this is going to connect to
our other
shortcut to loop back
oh nope okay I'm wrong I'm wrong about
that
all right special resistance
uh oh man okay so we got a couple
some decisions to make here we can drop
there
oh I don't want to miss that room so I'm
gonna
oh man can we make that
yeah right there
right here
shortcut darn it
it's gonna happen one day I'm calling it
I'm calling it there's gonna be a hidden
one at least
at least one place in this game
okay another beam
dude this is so reminiscent of
Dark Souls 2
there's a spot so similar to this
Remnant 2 apocalypse is that is that
like the hardest difficulty sunburst
man you guys are gonna make me want to
play that one next
I should look up the platinum trophy see
how difficult it is all right I don't
like this man I don't like that we
still oh there there's the Stargazer
let's go
whoa these guys
I saw them earlier
okay I'm just gonna heal
let us have another chat I saw you go
into the factory
but you're here so
wait
you came out of the factory
that's a new one
I thought you would have been burnt to a
crisp but look at you Paul intact
brother being too Frank is rude
we should praise him for being stronger
than he looks
why not join forces our cards right and
we could defeat the villains who rule
this area
they're the black rabbit Brotherhood
bodies who torments the residents around
here
we heard their Hideout is stuffed with
treasure and it's a good time to
liberate this place as well
pretty sweet deal don't you think
all you have to do is create a
distraction that's it the rest we can
handle
so
you're gonna do it
oh no I mean I think I would right
let me look at my collectible guide here
slim Shack key we did all of that
um
I'm pretty sure we should accept it
wait a second I'm not seeing this
anywhere
I'm not seeing it in my guide
the Platinum 2 is easy you don't even
need to play on the no death oh wow
wow wow wow
yeah that makes a big difference if you
don't have to do that
okay there's nothing in the Collectibles
guide about this so
I'm doing my live playthrough Rod is
there any reason that I wouldn't
accept this
just don't want to mess anything up
have to replay an extra time
sure I'm not missing anywhere on here
where it says
usually they the the guide that I'm
looking at for the Collectibles it tells
you
doesn't matter what you choose okay good
deal smart choice look at our smart
friend gato
where no slouches in the fisticuffs
Department in a pinch dude I want his
armor over there and watch for hidden
threats something tells me we're gonna
have a chance to get it at some point I
like it let's
okay can I talk to you
nope you don't want to talk
what did I even just agree to
I forgot what they
this is something that's just gonna
happen automatically I hope I like it
can we open this now
no we cannot
what about this
hmm
I think I should go upgrade
oh if you don't help them you have to
fight them at the end game interesting
yeah let's go back to the hotel
let us see no trophy is tied to them
gotcha good to know
good to know
oh my gosh it's almost two o'clock
sheesh
I haven't even eaten lunch I didn't
realize it was so late already
uh let's see do I have enough
I think I might need a little bit more
yeah we need four thousand five forty
Okay so
four thousand five forty so we need
about another thousand
so that's 500
yeah so I think if we do this
if we do this
and then let's do all of these
I'll use my power
kind of wonder if we should do more
stamina
let's just do motivity for now
even though I may respect later to use
different weapons
all right you know what guys I think I'm
gonna I think I'm gonna end it there
actually sorry Mr Keys you just you just
got back I haven't had lunch I think I'm
gonna end it there
but this was fun man I enjoyed doing
this uh streaming it straight from the
PS5 I'm gonna have to listen to it back
though and see how bad the audio is
because I know it's not anywhere nearly
as good as my normal audio
uh fourth quarter so motivity is
basically like the strength stat for
this game
yeah
so that's what
basically it only it matters in the
sense of the types of weapons you're
using so like the weapon I'm using right
now it has a b scaling with motivity
which when that's what I'm focusing on
that's pretty good
if it had an a scaling that'd be that'd
be even better but
yeah and technique is is dexterity
that's
the souls
version of it
yeah Dylan uh Dylan Anna Sunburst thank
you guys for being here
I can't wait till I'm finished with this
game so I can do the uh the full the
full trophy video it's gonna be so fun
it's gonna be a lot of fun for this one
all right well uh
hope you guys all have a great rest of
your Monday have a great week I'm trying
to figure out how how do I actually end
the stream for this
oh wait first I have to stop the
recording and then I go into broadcast
okay there it is stop broadcast all
right all right here we go as always
guys thank you all so much for watching
and I will talk to you again soon